I modelli di programmazione sono specifiche fondamentali che definiscono
come il software è strutturato
ed eseguito; forniscono un framework
agli sviluppatori per esprimere gli algoritmi
e organizzare il codice, spesso astraendo i dettagli di basso livello
dell'hardware sottostante o dell'ambiente di esecuzione
modelli diversi si adattano a diversi tipi di problemi
e architetture hardware, offrendo
diversi livelli di astrazione
e controllo. In questo capitolo
esamineremo i modelli di programmazione quantistica e classica
e vedremo come combinarli per creare algoritmi
più avanzati
inizieremo con il modello di programmazione
per un computer quantistico. Un modello di programmazione fondamentale
noto a quasi tutti gli sviluppatori di quantum computing
è il quantum circuit. Non entreremo
nei dettagli dei quantum circuit
qui, poiché disponiamo già di molte ottime risorse,
tra cui una lezione di Joan Waters
menzioneremo solo che il circuit è composto da
un insieme di linee chiamate wire, che rappresentano i qubit,
nonché da gate, che rappresentano operazioni sugli stati quantistici,
e da un insieme di misurazioni
un altro concetto importante del modello di programmazione
per
queste primitive rappresentano le attività più comuni
che gli utenti cercano di svolgere con il computer quantistico
al momento sono disponibili due primitive:
Sampler ed Estimator. Sampler ti consente di
campionare uno stato preparato da un quantum circuit,
mentre Estimator ti permette di stimare il valore atteso di
un'osservabile per un sistema nello stato preparato dal tuo quantum
circuit. Il concetto finale
di cui parleremo in questa sezione
è la transpilazione. La transpilazione
è il processo di riscrittura di un circuit di input
per adattarlo alla topologia di un dispositivo quantistico
specifico
per l'esecuzione su computer quantistici rumorosi
in modo simile ai compilatori classici,
una routine del transpiler modifica gradualmente
la struttura del circuit applicando una serie di passi
parliamo ora dei modelli di programmazione classica
esistono molti modelli di programmazione
per i computer classici,
ma in questo capitolo ci concentreremo su due:
la programmazione parallela, il più diffuso,
e il task workflow. Usando questi due modelli
in combinazione con i modelli di programmazione quantistica,
si può esprimere praticamente qualsiasi workflow ibrido
quantistico-classico di qualsiasi complessità
il modello di programmazione parallela
suddivide un programma in sottoproblemi che possono essere eseguiti
contemporaneamente. Esistono due paradigmi principali di programmazione parallela:
parallelismo a memoria condivisa e parallelismo a memoria distribuita
per i nostri scopi, concentriamoci sul modello a memoria distribuita
un modello a memoria distribuita
utilizza processi indipendenti su core separati
o nodi, dove ogni processo ha la propria memoria
e la comunicazione avviene tramite message passing. Ci sono
alcuni concetti utili da conoscere
il primo è il processo,
che è un'istanza indipendente del programma
in esecuzione su un core separato
c'è anche il rank, che è un identificatore univoco del processo,
e poi c'è il modello Single Program
Multiple Data (SPMD),
che è un modello di astrazione
per il calcolo in cui una singola istanza del programma
viene distribuita su più nodi
quindi il codice sorgente è lo stesso,
ma i dati su quei nodi sono diversi
l'esecuzione nel modello di programmazione parallela
avviene nel modo seguente:
un singolo programma viene distribuito su più nodi
e avvia più processi paralleli
il flusso di controllo del programma è determinato dal rank,
ovvero dall'identificatore del processo,
e la comunicazione avviene
tramite message passing
il modello di programmazione task workflow
astrae il calcolo in un grafo o DAG (grafo aciclico diretto),
dove ogni nodo del grafo è un task specifico
o job, e gli archi rappresentano dipendenze e dati
esempi si trovano nella nostra documentazione
dopotutto, la sequenza di cui parliamo sempre nel quantum
computing — mapping, ottimizzazione,
esecuzione e post-processing —
è un modello di programmazione task workflow
in cui tutti i task vengono eseguiti uno dopo
l'altro nella pipeline,
ma con i task workflow
non siamo vincolati all'ordine di esecuzione sequenziale
e possiamo eseguire task in parallelo
ogni task o workflow può essere un intero job parallelo
autonomo, quindi puoi combinare
questi modelli per descrivere algoritmi
di qualsiasi complessità.
Proviamo ad applicare alcuni dei concetti appresi
al codice. Prima proveremo a eseguire un semplice hello world
usando il paradigma di programmazione parallela
useremo Open MPI,
che è l'implementazione del protocollo MPI,
lo standard per il message passing
nella programmazione parallela
per prima cosa dobbiamo preparare il nostro programma
qui usiamo mpi4py,
che è il binding Python
per MPI e, come puoi vedere, usiamo il rank per decidere
il flusso di controllo del programma
controlliamo ora il nostro script di submission.
Come puoi vedere, useremo due nodi,
un task per nodo nella partizione normale
e avviamo il programma. Aspettiamo un momento
e possiamo controllare i risultati del nostro job
come puoi vedere, abbiamo gli output del log del nostro programma
qui abbiamo usato due nodi e due processi,
identificati da un rank
come puoi vedere nell'output
rank zero e rank one, usati per decidere
il flusso di controllo del nostro programma
come puoi vedere, il processo rank zero ha inviato
un payload al processo rank one,
e il processo rank one lo ha ricevuto
parliamo anche dei task workflow
esistono strumenti chiamati sistemi
di gestione dei workflow, progettati specificamente
per eseguire workflow complessi
ma per non complicare troppo le cose, useremo la funzionalità integrata
di dipendenza di Slurm
per costruire questi gruppi computazionali
prima dobbiamo preparare i task del nostro workflow
è lo stesso codice di prima
il vantaggio di avere ognuno di questi task —
mapping, ottimizzazione, esecuzione
e post-processing — come passi separati
è che possiamo specificare requisiti di risorse unici
per ciascun task. Ad esempio, mapping, ottimizzazione
e post-processing non hanno bisogno
di accedere a risorse quantistiche,
quindi possiamo eseguirli sulla partizione classica.
Il task di esecuzione invece avrà bisogno
di risorse quantistiche, quindi lo eseguiremo sulla partizione quantistica
partition.
Usiamo ora la funzionalità di dipendenza per concatenare i task
in un workflow.
Come puoi vedere, stiamo ancora eseguendo
il nostro sbatch con il flag --parsable,
che restituirà il job ID
e poi potremo passare questo job ID
come dipendenza agli altri task
per i job. Come puoi vedere, stiamo eseguendo
i job nel workflow con la dipendenza
una volta completato l'intero workflow, possiamo controllare i risultati.
E come puoi vedere, abbiamo il nostro valore di expectation value.
E possiamo anche controllare tutti i
risultati di ciascuno dei passi.
Che sono anche qui.
E questo è tutto per la sezione sui modelli di programmazione
nel prossimo capitolo parleremo degli algoritmi avanzati
più avanzati